you also looked at someone that drank
their own urine it was a contestant on
Canadian Idol called will blunderfield
just got off the phone with him and I
just thought what a sweet young man but
drinks his own piss and not just his own
piss as it turns out there's a whole
video where he's like and it's got a
little bit of pre-cum in it drinking
your own urine is one of these strangely
recurrent practices so it's still used
in traditional medicine in sub-Saharan
Africa and places like that but it has
been something that hippies have kind of
done frequently he had had an eye
condition strabismus where one of his
eyes didn't quite track properly and had
spent most of his childhood being
medicalized and then he came out as gay
and was essentially gay bashed when he
was holding his first boyfriend's hand
and went to a psychiatrist or therapist
to talk about it and instead of being
given talking therapy really was put on
pills and I understood from those two
experiences why someone would get to the
place where they are very skeptical of
mainstream traditional medicine why they
don't want to be within what he calls
the allopathic system but I wanted to
try and do more than the standard
anti-vaxx thing of saying well these
people are just wrong and kind of
understand psychologically how someone
would get to those opinions